now why are these people smiling about
the 1.3 trillion dollar spending package
passed by the house today Chuck Schumer
explain your joy this spending agreement
brings the era of austerity to an
unceremonious end we Democrats are
really happy with what we were able to
accomplish on a number of priorities
that Democrats have fought for all along
Democrats are thrilled because they're
about to secure runaway spending that
was out of reach even under Obama
discretionary spending is skyrocketing
no more budget caps for this gang
meanwhile Republicans are tripping all
over themselves even he's seen this
they're trying to justify this
boondoggle now I realize they're up
against as usual government shutdown but
the largest military expenditure in 14
years and an explosion in discretionary
spending is not going to pave the way to
victory in November and by the way if
you're going to increase military
funding this much how about even the
pretense of trying to offset some of
that with spending cuts once a fiscal
Hawk when he was in Congress Budget
Director Mick Mulvaney he tried mightily
today to sell this rotten piece of fish
we've talked for the last I don't know
three four five six months about trying
to get the president's priorities funded
and this omnibus bill does that when we
look at the bill we have to weigh what
we asked for and what we had to give
away to give it is it perfect
no is it exactly what we asked for in
the budget No what are we ever going to
get that no that's not how the process
works well thanks for the tutorial when
the American people have given you both
houses of Congress and the White House
it said it's what you all said you
needed it should be the way the process
works director Mulvaney the GOP just
cannot get its act together the most
important thing that president promised
his number-one priority was getting that
border wall built did that
lost on the people in Congress did they
not catch them hundreds of times he
mentioned it and during the rallies he
asked Congress for 1.6 billion dollars
to build 74 miles of concrete wall
well this omnibus orgy of spending
dedicates a puny 641 million dollars to
something called border reinforcements
but Speaker Paul Ryan says I don't worry
about it we fund government one year at
a time that's how the budget process
works sure so we're gonna fund the wall
one year at a time in this case for the
next six months you need fences you need
cameras senior electronic devices you
need these um the the aerial devices to
be able to place it in the mountainous
areas you can't build a wall over
mountain so you need cameras and you
need drones up there so it's a border
wall system it's different kinds of wall
based on different kinds of conditions
on the ground and that's what we fund oh
my god just washington-speak sensors
extra fence ends fencing sensors what
are these iPhones Aveda drones this is
not what the president promised he vowed
to build a wall it is not complicated
and now we have the biggest spending
bill in history and it sets aside 640
million dollars to supposedly fund wall
construction for one year my friends I
hate to say this is that but as I see it
right now tonight the wall is never
gonna happen because as we've dug into
this and really looked into this this
bill doesn't fund the wall at all in
fact the bill only pays for construction
I can't believe I'm saying this of
see-through fencing but Congress
actually authorized I remember this back
in 2006 the omnibus bill that we're
talking about tonight funds 33 miles of
new barriers and replacement fencing for
59 miles but understand this there is no
wall construction all told you the
taxpayer will reef ence part of the
border for a grand total of wait for it
92 miles you know what that looks like
it looks like this 92 miles see that
little white spot we should have made it
pink a little white spot look how big
the border is that why bother at all why
don't we just put the big didn t those
welcome mat at the border because it
doesn't matter if the Republicans lose
the midterms the Democrats will never
fund this thing and will be reliant upon
Paul Ryan sensors and a few drones and
replacement fencing to protect America I
will repeat this is not what the
American people voted for and you know
what really gets me it's an
embarrassment to the president he knew
how to win this election and the
Republicans the swamp want to take it
away from him
last week he was at the border
inspecting wall prototypes when he said
this look at the fence and it's a very
powerful fence
not doing the trick because they cut
holes in it and then they're patching
holes all the time
I'm just looking you have hundreds of
holes cut in and patched so the fence is
not strong enough it's not the right
idea but for those people if you don't
have a wall system
you're gonna have we're not gonna have a
country okay I agree with him it can't
be fences that are repaired and
terminally with holes in them see if you
don't have a wall you don't have a
country today there was a meeting of
Millennials at the White House it was it
was pretty cool and it is great to hear
their concerns on a variety of topics
but how about the concern that the
government and this type of omnibus
spending bill is mortgaging away their
future the money that's being spent and
borrowed and printed this is congressman
Dave brat they're not we're putting all
this on the kids credit card its
intergenerational theft of the first
magnitude it's immoral it's unethical
and that we have to make a change we are
saddling the next generation with
ever-growing debt and for what if we
truly cared about the Millennials we
would firstly keep them safe by
immediately funding the border wall then
we would find real cuts throughout the
federal budget to offset these radical
expenditures so they wouldn't be stuck
with the bill long after that military
hardware and that flimsy border fence
we're buying have all rusted away we can
do better we must do better or
Republicans do not deserve to be in the
majority and that's the angle